hey everyone this is steve weintraub
with collider and i am thrilled to be
with sir ben kingsley to talk about
dollyland wonderful to be here sir i'm
going to say this to you um you will not
remember this but many many years ago
when collider was a much smaller
operation
i was thrilled i mean literally thrilled
and over the moon because i got to talk
to you for the wackness at sundance
and at the time the site was just a much
smaller operation and the concept that i
was going to talk to you for a movie
blew my mind and you were so gracious
and kind and just i i walked away just
so
just grateful for the experience and
i've wanted to thank you and i just
wanted to say sincerely thank you i'm
glad i left a good smell behind
well you know something um
the thing that i have find
what i love about your work is it's so
can be so vastly different
yet they're all anchored by your strong
performances which leads me to dollyland
thank you um i obviously loved your work
in this and i'm a huge fan of dolly
but i did not actually understand
a lot of the stuff that went happened in
the 70s so i found this to be very
fascinating because i learned a lot
i would imagine you get offered a lot of
scripts i have to ask you what was it
about this one in this character that
said i have to do this
quite honestly
i find dali's work
sublime and beautiful
provoking
and
something in me recognizes what he's
trying to say as an artist i don't know
what it is i'm certainly not equating
my
my humble craftsmanship with his genius
but there is
a resonance now this is not always
essential when playing a character but
it is a bonus sometimes and um
what what
this script and portraying him
encouraged me to do thanks to the
wonderful mary harem
was to take risks as an actor
equivalent to the risks he took as a
painter
i think if an actor i've just been with
the with my my heroine tilda swinton and
i can quote her or misquote her but i
know she has said there's an awful lot
of nonsense talked about acting
and acting is a is a combination
of empathy and transformation
and
that applied to dali
means that i the humble actor or
portrait artist have to take risks as an
actor
parallel to the risks he took as a
painter therefore i cannot give a
careful performance that for me was a
really
attractive exercise beyond the man
himself whom i
who my if i if i were in his company
would be quite intimidated by him but i
think i would just follow him
as part of his party entourage and say i
want to be with that guy
one of the things sometimes titles don't
work for me but after seeing this film
dali land is literally the perfect title
because it is literally this land of
characters and eccentric people i i
think the title is perfect
also
mary mary's choice of title
is enhanced by
the performance of chris browning
who is the lens
or the prism
through which we see dali
and because chris gave such a pure
performance
therefore his
i think he parallel also allowed the
parallel between actor and character to
to coexist
because i know that being so young in
his career
that he was um taking first steps and
allowed himself
to be surprised as an actor
and surprised as a character
therefore
his his energy transmits to the audience
i can't quite believe i'm here
i mean that i mean that most sincerely
and kindly to him
one of the things i'm fascinated by with
an act with all actors is being able to
let go of the character that you're
playing you have played so many iconic
roles and delivered so many vastly
different performances are you able at
this moment when a film wraps or a
project you're involved with raps to
immediately let go of the character
you're playing or do you feel that it's
like a good week or two where you still
feel remnants
i think that
perhaps
as an actor
i could
try and describe myself as a portrait
artist
and therefore
on a really good day with a really
lovely project
it is as if dali is in my studio
and i am painting him
so i have to say
that
after
the last day of filming which was an
extraordinary day
i won't go into details now but it was
quite extraordinary i missed him
terribly
um
every time one of the things that i
found with speaking to actors is that
when they're shooting a project there
will be a day on the shoot that they are
either very nervous about or very
excited about they know that it'll be a
challenging day where they might have to
go deep and find something inside them
to bring to the to life
on dali land what day was that for you
i remember speaking
with our wonderful producer
chris curling chris curling on the day
and i said to him after the day had
finished
i did not know at the beginning of the
day
how i was going to get through the day
but at the end of the day i didn't want
it to finish
this day was when i was playing dali
dying
in a wheelchair
with a tube
in his nostril because
he couldn't eat without food being
passed through his knot
a devastating
journey
from the most gloriously charismatic
man
to an almost cadaver in a wheelchair
and i also spoke catalan
and i reproduced
documentary footage of dali in the
hospital and i was allowed thanks to
mary's graciousness i was allowed to
recreate that scene in the hospital as
myself portraying dolly dying
that for me
was one of the most extraordinary days
of my career i don't wish to colour it
in any way
but but by by pushing or manipulating
the audience's response to that day but
since you ask and it's a glorious
question i have to say that that day i
will remember
forever
something i i obviously knew about dolly
but i didn't really i didn't know that
much about his relationship with with
gala um wait i said that right yes and
um
yeah i'm sorry that i knew i was saying
it wrong i was like i was like i'm like
i'm saying that this is not right that's
just that's just his version of it right
um uh but i didn't know about their
relationship and and what they each sort
of brought to it um how much did you
actually know about his personal
relationship and his marriage prior to
taking on the project well i i did know
a little and then the script
mapped it out so perfectly
because mary and john realized that it
was amongst other things a story of a
marriage or the disintegration
of a marriage
it's like an autopsy of a relationship
um
and for me
it made complete sense
complete sense
because
of of of the refusal
in dali to mature from a child
to remain
plastic and and careless and free as a
child throughout the whole of his life
what does that personality need
a mother
and either that role is resented at
times
because of your dependency upon it or
it's blessed times and i think the film
embraces both
ends of that spectrum
something also that the film shines a
light on is the and i don't want to get
too deep into it but the corruption in
the art world which is something that's
prevalent since i mean it keeps going um
uh can you sort of talk about is that
something that you were familiar with is
that something that um because i think
it's something that people
you know i don't want to get too deep
into that aspect of the film but um if
you could talk a little bit about that
it is a great tragedy
that a genuine
creative gesture
can be hijacked
for
the worst possible motives that's really
all i can say that it is it is a tragedy
that something
that genuinely and purely comes from the
heart
is hijacked by others
for
a corrupt agenda i'm curious obviously
dalia is known for his mustache and the
way he looks and i'm curious if you
could talk about how long and this is
i'm not sure if you worked with the
costume designer how it all came
together but how you ultimately decided
on the exact mustache and your look of
dolly in the film
i worked with suzanne stokes-munten
and i was also sent a book of
photographs
a book of collections of his moustache
looks
by a very dear friend of mine and we
chose
the most iconic
because what you have to be
what you have to present to the audience
is an instantly recognizable and
consistent image although he changed his
look several times we had to decide upon
a look
that said to the audience immediately
dali
and and and we honed in on that
particular look suzanna and myself and
i'm very grateful to her for her
wonderful work on the film i believe you
shot the movie over five weeks which is
very fast very fast and for people that
don't realize that's a very fast shoot
do you as an actor is that something
that you relish where it's gonna be that
kind of a tight schedule
where everyone has to be on their game
you don't have a lot of takes you gotta
get it or do you sort of prefer the
longer shoot where it's a little bit
slower and more maybe you're only
shooting a page or two in a day
well because this is
an interview
that will not be the best kept secret in
town
i'm reluctant to say that i love to work
under pressure because then they'll say
oh you can get kingsley to do three
months work in four weeks
um which can which can be uh harrowing
um
let it take the time it takes
let it take the time that is appropriate
to the material
mary worked with great accuracy and
great skill because she knew exactly
what she wanted provided the director is
in charge of every second and uses it
judiciously
um
let's let's have all the time in the
world so i believe when you signed on to
work with marvel to do something in the
marvel universe you had no idea where it
was all gonna go are you surprised at
how much fans love your work in the
marvel universe and the fact that you're
gonna be i guess going back to it
well um i haven't actually
broken the news to trev
that he is about to embark on
his third incarnation
but if i can find him
in
in some pub in liverpool i shall tell
him
gently and quietly in a corner trev
we're
and i think you'll be delighted
are you surprised of van i love your
work in in the mcu and i'm sure you hear
from fans all the time that they love it
are do you do you feel that love
well uh um let me let me um
speculate on on why i think there is
something
again like dali
there is something
of the child
in trev and there is something pure
in trev and i perhaps that
that touches the
the unconscious in the audience i don't
really know
that's probably a ludicrous answer but
no i i had to go yeah listen uh i'm i
have to stop there and i'm just gonna
say again a sincere with all my heart
thank you for coming in today to talk
about dali land and i wish you nothing
but the best you're very kind thank you